tirer le n'est pas là je crois que je
l'ai traité de petits pakistanais et je
crois qu'il fait la gueule on a eu il
est là voilà il distribue des roses
comme un petit pakistanais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors Cyril c'est la famille ça ce sont
les trois sœurs de Cyril Hanouna merci
les filles
Nobel
alors Cyril je suis désolé je vais
traiter de petits pakistanais bien pris
j'adore ouais mais en fait c'est faux
vous êtes pas petit
Cyril Hanouna rebonsoir vous êtes ici ce
soir parce que depuis septembre vous
êtes celui dans tout le monde parle
Touche pas à mon poste cartonne cette
semaine vous avez encore battu mercredi
le Grand Journal ouais mais ça faut pas
le dire il faut le dire on n'est pas
loin de M6
très très bien et sur Europe 1 les pieds
dans le plat qui est en train de bien
s'installer c'est vrai qu'à force même
vous vous commencez à vous demander ce
que les gens vous trouvent en fait
à part ma femme voilà à qui je ne plais
plus du tout
à l'heure il m'a sauté dans les bras
deux minutes je sais que tu aimes la
culture mais tu te calmes ça va alors
Cyril sur D8 en fait il faut se demander
quelle émission vous présentez pas quoi
si vous avez une gastro la chaîne ferme
pendant trois semaines
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression que j'ai un âge de
chien c'est à dire qu'il faut multiplier
mon âge par 7 tellement on voit dans la
journée il y a plusieurs vies quoi donc
quand vous étiez dans le bureau d'un
directeur de chaîne il demandait la
sécurité de venir ouais c'est vrai ça
m'est arrivé c'est dingue vous avez du
succès on est ravi faut dire que vous
savez vous renouveler quand même regarde
[Rires]
il est magnifique il est magnifique et
magnifique
[Rires]
[Musique]
voilà c'est magnifique alors vos auteurs
ils sont pas chier c'est magnifique
c'est magnifique c'est magnifique il va
falloir que j'arrête de le dire non
franchement je vais essayer pour vous
allez le prix Michel Drucker 2014
ça c'est bon alors ce qui est le plus
dingue si vous êtes déjà entré dans la
légende les gens qui vous initent qui
vous partent regardez
cyril est omniprésent à la télé avec
plus de 35 heures d'antenne par semaine
du coup on se demande quand il a le
temps de travailler
[Rires]
pour son émission Cyril c'est entouré
d'une bande de chroniqueurs permanente
chez les mecs il y a Enora Malagré j'ai
jamais vu une émission aussi vulgaire
c'est permisieuse c'est un scandale il
faut que cette émission s'arrête [__]
bordel c'est vulgaire vas-y [__] c'est
le mec le plus féministe de la banque
t'as vu l'image des meufs dans cette
émission sérieux on est comme ça je peux
plus voir ce genre d'émission tu peux
plus voir personne qu'est-ce qui se
passe lumière juste à côté de lui il y a
l'humoriste Jean-Luc Lemoine cette
émission mais t'es pas sérieux t'es pas
sérieux tu es à côté de la queue plat
mon gars tu es à côté de la queue plat
animé c'est un métier se pose bouffon là
avec ses costumes en carton et son décor
en nickel mais je m'en fous moi elle
vient ici je la fissure je vais lui
[__] sa mère
[Musique]
c'est bien allumer bravo
ah c'est fort alors cette année est
marqué par l'arrivée de Nabilla tous les
soirs dans Touche pas on pose ou
décrypter la télé et Nabilla essaye de
décrypter ce que vous dites en vrai
c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
qu'on parle en ancien français tout ça
quoi quand on lui écrit un truc la
dernière fois c'est con tu m'as écrits
alors est-ce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
des stars qui ne veulent pas venir style
Kad Merad Omar Sy parce que Nabilla
voilà il a démenti même cadre il a dit
que c'était
Omar si tu me regardes frérot tu peux
démentir parce qu'après Nabilla est pas
bien et elle veut pas dormir à la maison
donc on n'arrange pas merci frère alors
à notre époque la télé c'est comme la
box et le rap hein ça clash vous avez
clacher tout le PAF moi ce que j'aime
c'est ce que vous dites après vous
clasher quelqu'un et vous dites je
l'aime beaucoup en plus c'est vrai c'est
ça faites moi je l'aime beaucoup en plus
non franchement je l'aime beaucoup en
plus
on va juste citer la liste des mecs que
vous avez clashé il y a Denisot
en plus j'adore Bouvard à Bouvard on est
venu super pote à la maison maintenant
chacun fait sa vie mais s'il veut venir
dormir à la maison la plupart
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme quand nous on va la
confession pour faire un peu MZ on va
dire que c'est notre Kippour aujourd'hui
voilà d'accord
[Applaudissements]
et la vraie vie comment ça va Cyril la
vraie vie ça va ça va Thierry on essaie
de d'avancer papa pas facile quand même
non non c'est pas tous les jours rose le
soir quand vous rentrez chez vous vos
enfants sont couchés
votre femme aussi oui ma mère aussi
vous mangez une pizza seule oui seule
face aux champignons à 1h du matin vous
la décongelé la pizza quand même non
c'est pour ça que j'ai perdu une dent en
direct un jour je vais pouvoir continuer
longtemps comme ça
tant qu'on arrête pas on continue mais à
mon avis on va finir par m'arrêter vous
sacrifier votre vie privée en fait je
rentre plus trop tard maintenant vous
dites par exemple le week-end je prends
du temps pour ma femme et mes enfants
mais quand on vous appelle le week-end
vous répondez c'est vrai que vous m'avez
déjà pris le week-end vous leur réponds
pas ma femme
on passe maintenant à la question de
Jean-Mi
[Musique]
oh mon petit Jean-Mi il est mignon
il veut me remplacer ce connard bon
pose ta question Jean-Mi Cyril tu fais
du sport tu ne te drop pas tu es fidèle
à ta femme alors pourquoi tu fais de la
télé
la raison non mais c'est vrai il a
raison c'est vrai que il faut que je
trouve un truc qui ne fait pas ça pour
élargir encore même l'argent on est sur
des 8
pas non plus
non non non franchement non c'est pour
vraiment j'avais peu d'amis maintenant
depuis que je fais de la télé j'ai un
tas de nouveaux amis j'ai plein d'amis
j'ai pas les plans
[Applaudissements]
tu me fais la danse des sardines
[Musique]
c'est génial merci Jean-Louis et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu